would you ever do anything again with
the whole Firefly Serenity world yeah I
laying some things to rest I'll
but what was your experience with Joss
Whedon it was fine actually I I have no
like
horrible stories or feelings towards him
you know he could be a little like
egotistical and like but you never saw
what of the other people see you just
weren't privileged I didn't which does
not let me just be very clear invalidate
anything or or I'm not saying anybody's
making anything up like I I that was not
my experience I mean I've certainly
experienced sexism and weird situations
at work like most women have but I I
don't it's I don't leave a lot of room
for that if that makes sense I'm kind of
a straight shooter you know this about
me so if somebody is gonna say something
or do something I think I would deal
with it immediately yeah oh yeah you
would immediately if you don't like
something you let everybody know yeah
you have that Mirena look I know that
look